hey guys I'm sure we all remember a
normal night starts last in the ninth
episode of the very first season of Game
of Thrones by the name Baylor which
beside providing us the clear sign that
this series is very different than any
other as I've learned that anyone can
die at any moment also was one of the
most important episodes of the series as
it was one of numerous main event that
led the seven kingdoms in the state of
chaos into a major civil war known as
the war of the five kings
however today I'm not going to talk
about war of the five kings or about how
unique game of journal series is today
I'm going to talk about last first that
Eddard Stark was muttering to himself a
moment before he was beheaded by Sir
Ilyn with Ned's
own Valyrian steel sword words that
could be of tremendous importance but
could also be nothing more than a prayer
to the old gods in his dying moments
after watching this horrible scene
numerous times it reminds me a lot on
the scene from season 6 finale cinder
took place in the Tower of joy mature
learners decided not to reveal Joshu
name but the most important part of
leiana's last waged as she entrusted to
her brother Ned cannot be heard in my
opinion both Ned less first and Leanna's
last wish that she whisper internets
here will be revealed in the upcoming
seasons additionally I think those two
scenes Ned's whispering to himself and
Leanna's whisper to her brother Ned are
connected as I believe Ned last words
were I kept my promise
as most of you have probably already
figured it out at this point
Ned whispering I kept my promise would
match with Leanna's last words which
were promised me which is said to her
brother Ned whispering to himself I kept
my promise would actually make a lot of
sense as Ned kept his promise that he
gave to his dying sister which was the
protector Sarkis father's Prince Rhaegar
Targaryen
Ned protected Liana son by keeping a
secret to himself with resolving to pass
off his sister's son as his own bastard
and by deciding not to use his nephews
birth name which Lina whispered to him a
few moments before her death but rather
named him after his friend and mentor
Jon Arryn as gesture names was from the
Targaryen style name that would have
given away John's real parentage with
all this being said Ned muttering to
himself I kept my promise most certainly
is not beyond the realm of possibilities
and I'm sure most of you would agree as
I reverse the already mentioned ninth
episode of the first season as I was
rewatching nicely
words that he muttered to himself it
really seems like Nats last verse were
Valar morghulis
which beside meaning all men Mazda I
wouldn't make any sense Fernet start to
say it in his final moments as it is a
common greeting in Braavos not in
Winterfell not in the north not invest
arose as much as it really looks like
net is saying Valar morghulis and as
much as Ned Stark saying a greeting in
high Valyrian language that is common in
Braavos sounds ridiculous it might be a
hidden key in that Ned Stark is actually
alive because if naturally said Valar
morghulis
before his beheading it might be some
kind of proof that is going favor to my
theory that I brought you a few months
ago basically in that theory the most
honorable man in the Seven Kingdoms
Eddard Stark is actually alive this
whole time they'll demand beheaded by
Searle and Bane on the steps of the
great Sept of Baelor was not actually
net himself but was rather the faceless
man very Ned's face
well Syrio Forel was of the greatest
importance as in this theory not only
that syria provided help to ned but he's
also taken the faith of the faceless man
who sacrificed his life for Ned was
having among few other which is the face
of full erotic criminal jaqen H'ghar
i know that big amount of you have
already rejected this theory even before
you've heard it mostly because most of
you don't believe that the faceless man
can wear a face of someone that is alive
cannot create a face in order to portray
someone else but you might be wrong as
there was a scene that took place in the
final episode of the fifth season a
scene in rejecting cigar warrior his
face whose standing just beside him I've
seen that might have confirmed that the
faceless man assassins can mirror face
of a person that is not dead person that
is still alive since they might be able
to create a mask from other faces that
could look just like the face of the
person they want to portray
if you're interested in more details
about this theory of mine feel free to
check out my previous videos but be
aware that this is a theory supported
don't leave it a few flags that are
going favor to this theory which some
are considering as a proof Center hidden
hints one has less first being Valar
morghulis
what's there owing to his possibility of
this theory to come true and as always
let me know your opinion about all of
this do you think Ned's last words were
I kept my promise or do you think others
last words weren't even Eddard's
but were the last words of the faceless
man whose last words were Valar
morghulis let me know your thoughts in
the comment section down below I hope
you guys enjoyed
video if you did please make sure to
subscribe to our channel and I hope to
see in the next feed
[Music]
you